[Music]
you coached a celebrity football game is
that right
you were the country played I'm just
curious for the for the Super Bowl we
were invited to the Super Bowl of thing
I don't play football at all
I was the band guy I mean so I was like
sure oh I'll go but do I have to play
football and they said no if we can
figure something I can I be like an
assistant coach so I can like be like a
Harlem Globetrotters like walk up and
down and just stick you late wildly and
throw water filled things of confetti at
people right and they said sure yeah
absolutely so great so it's guys and
girls and that's the flag football and
but I was terrified because it's all
major football professionals that you're
playing against but then I started to
feel bad cuz I don't know anything about
the game I was a terrible coach and
everyone was playing and all of them are
sitting there playing exhausted looking
at me like what are you right you've got
a clipboard and you're like rages ref so
I and RD Laing was on our team he was
playing Artie Lange's playing in you're
not - I'm not play yeah so I'm like
y'all fine I'll play so I go in I'm
playing defense I'm terrible I'm nervous
I almost paralyzed a girl minutos yeah
Maria Menounos you almost paralyzed
Maria Menounos well I don't know who to
cover and so it's a SAN football and so
the hut hut and then they're running and
I'm going I'm covering already and they
throw it right to her she catches the
ball and she turned sideways and sort of
like hits the ground and I'm trying to
get her and my knee
catches like the small of her back oh my
gosh yeah didn't kick her like it just
happened but then it finished the plays
over and I'm getting back a feeling
really snugly and I look and I've
crippled a girl
any pain on the beach sand so yeah it
was wise that you probably didn't play